- Well, what is your,
do you mind showing us your bedroom?
I like it so far.
Like, can you show us
around just a tiny bit,
it looks so--
- Sure,
here I'm gonna turn around the camera.
- All right.
- There's my dog, Angel Grace.
See, she's on her bed.
See I got the ocean
there and the fireplace
and this is where my TV is
and I just want to tell you that,
you know, when I bought this house,
I was getting a divorce
from my first husband
and my life, I was,
you know, still on the show, The Nanny
and my life was very
complicated and intense
and busy and I needed something
that was extremely calming
and, you know, very pristine
and to make me feel very peaceful.
- You literally just,
it's like you were in
my last therapy session.
(laughing)
I was like, I literally,
I not only like got a new house,
it's very white and clean and orange,
it's the same reasoning
and I also read in my office here,
I looked at Kevin, our art department.
I was like, please help
me make this make sense.
I was like, I was like, I need to feel
clean, clean, cleansed
and I just wanted to feel happy
and it does, that,
- Well, I have to tell you.
- the colors make me feel
really good.
- Yeah, me too.
- Yeah.
- And colors do influence how you feel.
- And I just want to tell you that
now that you know,
everything's done and years have passed,
it's, we're actually
very happily divorced.
- I know, I know, I love the show.
Y'all did happily divorce, you had,
'cause he's--
- Yes,
and that inspired the show.
- Yeah, and you're actually
friends with your ex, right?
- Yes, yes.
We're the best of friends
and we're still writing partners.
You know, sometimes we,
like we marry people
because we love them
and I come from a very
provincial upbringing.
It seemed like that was
the next likely step,
but it's not always the right choice
and when you figure that out for yourself,
you don't have to and
I got this information
from a very wise old owl
and she said, don't throw the
baby out with the bath water,
just take what's good about it
and nurture the love in a new way
I think is probably the healthiest,
if you can do it.